passports restricted in Europe driving
licenses no longer valid in the EU
mobile phone roaming charges legal again
satellite access restricted and impacts
on seafaring energy data and even family
law the implications of the latest slew
of No Deal notices wide-ranging and
profound at home at work and on holiday
the job of the Cabinet this morning to
sign off the plans to make No Deal
brexit not the end of the world as the
PM has suggested the Cabinet briefed on
the consequences of a chaotic no deal by
the Bank of England governor Mark Carney
a recession house price is sliding by a
third and sterling falling to will
presented a range of situations and that
will have added to the considerations of
the No Deal situation and I think people
can take confidence in the work that's
going on to ensure that we have a smooth
exit from the European Union Emmanuel
macron Europe Minister sounding pretty
uncompromising on the way in to meet the
braces secretary after that cabinets
looking forward to a No Deal but we have
to be prepared later going much further
on the impact seen by France from no
deal with talk of grounded planes and
Eurostar not functioning is it a real
possibility that Euro stars coming from
London will be rejected and not allowed
on French soil on the 30th of March this
is what would happen among other
examples as you probably know this is
the reason why we need to prepare for a
No Deal the notices also confirmed some
big changes to business conditions
approvals for car manufacturing in the
UK no longer valid in Europe and vice
versa
after an Odile brexit and transferring
data made
difficult they say they don't want it
they say it's unlikely but government
policy is to accept that No Deal brexit
and all these consequences are a
possible outcome in six months time
business leaders argue the notices show
the economy being hit like a
sledgehammer but the Prime Minister
can't or won't make this case in this
way she needs these things to be
concerning enough to get her back
benches and public to reject No Deal
but not her handling of brexit or brexit
itself in lis voting cheshire there is
some surprise at these tangible impacts
of No Deal brexit if they happen the end
of a short term and I think yes because
we the independent country again is
worth it so much stuff that I don't
think anyone knew about I think we had
been told you know all the implications
if I'd known for instance that there
could be a border in Ireland all this No
Deal preparation designed to strengthen
to resumes hand in deal-making
with them Rochelle Barney and Donald
Tusk meeting today to prepare next
week's Saltzburg summit some fears that
all the talk of no deal is making what
none of the negotiators actually want
increasingly likely vital Islam Sky News
[Applause]
joins me now live from Westminster
fights well we're getting a bit more
details of what the Bank of England
governor has actually said today and
quite a stark warning on house prices
it's emerging yes well I know it sort of
mixes into one not particularly
appetizing pot I was told by a source
who heard the presentation that it
wasn't a prediction it was a worst-case
scenario but essentially if trading
connections are made difficult in that
scenario at the Bank of England
anticipates that sterling would slide
again that interest rates which were cut
in the wake of the referendum cut in the
way to the financial crisis that they
they wouldn't be able to cut indeed they
might even need to go up in the case of
a situation of sterling falling very
sharply indeed and it's that type of
crisis situation that there
referring to I think in this slide in
house price is a prediction of a No Deal
recession that was the start
presentation that was received
interestingly the response when you
expect to hear from breakfast of cabinet
ministers you expect them to be maybe a
little skeptical refer to this as
project fear and the like
well they didn't it was listen see
respectfully and it shaped the argument
and nodal cabinets for the rest of the
three hours so I think we will get
tomorrow reaction from conservative
Breck stirs never been the greatest fan
of Mark Carney the Bank of England
governor a stark presentation given to
cabinet this morning yes and in the
meantime what has the reaction been so
far to the No Deal papers that have been
released today yeah so we've heard the
macro background but it hasn't been
published it should be said but I think
the detail of some of these nodal papers
show the tangible impacts of No Deal
as now officially predicted by the
governor government in black-and-white
and you heard the impact potentially on
driving licenses not valid you'd need
driving permits potentially two
different driving permits if we were
driving through France to Spain turns
out there's potentially not enough
post-office counters to issue all of
those driving permits for next summer
passports Rome mobile phone roaming no
longer illegal the phone companies say
though that they would deal with that
but there's no legal protection there
that's just something for competition
and also big impacts also across the
business community whether its approval
of cars manufactured here all the flow
of data between continental Europe and
the UK big impacts one organization the
CBI saying would hit the economy like a
sledgehammer what's really interesting
though is you don't hear as yet the
Prime Minister making that case it's
almost like she's got to try and find
the kind of Goldilocks description that
No Deal she doesn't like the economic
impact of that but she doesn't want to
be too aggressive in saying it would be
a disaster because that would be bad for
her politically so a difficult tightrope
as ever for the prime minister to walk
as we hear these stark warnings from the
government the Bank of England but also
in the government's own preparedness
statements